[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud
con más romero sala ya que los dos
estamos vigentes salud debe agarrar a
esa micro mar bueno cual es un año cuál
es su animal ya sabe cuál es lo acabo de
buscar él le vale ro el del perro bueno
yo soy una serpiente creo que podemos
ser buenos amigos entonces nos la hace
así más lo intentaremos vamos a empezar
hablando de la diabetes una enfermedad
que en eeuu ha crecido durante toda esta
pandemia mar y que pues no es algo para
reírse tampoco no de hecho las alarmas
han sonado en todas las agencias de
salud de eeuu porque nunca antes se
había superado esa barrera de los 100
mil muertos nunca antes de la pandemia
digamos de hecho repasando las cifras
vemos que en 2019 las muertes por
diabetes fueron aproximadamente 87 mil
en 2020 ya crecieron un 17% y en 2021 un
15% ambos respecto a niveles pre
pandémicos esto es especialmente grave
porque la diabetes tipo 2 que es la que
es más común entre toda la población
estadounidense y también del mundo es
una diabetes prevenible surge sobre todo
a raíz de malos hábitos alimentarios de
salud de deporte entonces pues las
agencias de salud de eeuu
particularmente la comisión nacional
clínica del congreso de eeuu explicó un
poco estas tendencias y pidió acciones
escuchamos lo
si se mantiene la tendencia actual uno
de cada tres estadounidenses
desarrollará diabetes en su vida en eeuu
la diabetes es la principal causa de
seguir en adultos falla renal y
amputaciones de extremidades inferiores
y contribuye gravemente el número de
muertes por kobe 19 entre estas acciones
que se piden para prevenir esto de estos
números tan alarmantes no sólo son
acciones médicas sino que también se
piden acciones sociales muy concretas
porque se sabe que entre las víctimas de
diabetes son principalmente personas de
ingresos bajos o personas racial izadas
en eeuu y que algunas medidas sociales
como por ejemplo garantizar el derecho a
la vivienda o mejorar la capacidad
adquisitiva de estas personas harían que
tuvieran la posibilidad de tener mejores
hábitos de salud y eso haría pues que se
desarrollaran menos enfermedad que
afecta a eeuu y a un montón de los
países del norte global claro mari
también hablamos aquí recuerdo que eso
también está relacionado con la
nutrición por falta de ingresos para
tener una buena variedad de alimentos
que nos puedan nutrir
bueno empieza a sufrir una información
sobre la nueva su variante o micrón yo
me río para no llorar que sabemos sobre
esto hay que preocuparnos no tanto no
tanto haber en regenerar la comunidad
científica está sólo levemente
preocupada y empezamos a ver qué es
queda algo más contagiosa empiezan a
surgir estás cifras que confirman
algunos de los temores que teníamos y es
que después de estudiar a ocho mil
familias en dinamarca que fue el primer
el primer país de hecho donde se detectó
este está sub variante se ve que tras de
estar expuesto a la variante original de
o micro n se ve a uno se tiene un 29 por
ciento de posibilidades de contagiarse
eso aumenta hasta el 39 por ciento si se
estuvo expuesto a ba2 que es esta
segunda sub variante la nueva sub
variante de omicron en total eso
significa que es alrededor de un 33 por
ciento más contagiosa que la primera eso
sí se cree que no es más grave
simplemente algo más contagiosa y que lo
que podría pasar es que se alargue un
poco este descenso de los casos que
creíamos o esperábamos todos que fuera a
ser rápido y que probablemente no
sucederá más y lo que sí alertó la
organización mundial de la salud mar es
de las consecuencias el acto de residuos
generados por esta pandemia pues sí de
hecho una preocupación que surgió desde
el inicio un poco de la pandemia esta
cantidad de residuos generados tanto por
los centros médicos como por las
personas que se tratan de proteger de
los contagios de kobin 19 estas son las
estimaciones de la organización mundial
de la salud
de extracción generador residuos extra
el volumen se ha multiplicado por 3 o 4
durante la pandemia esa cifra se
multiplica por 10 en centros que no
pueden reciclar las instalaciones
sanitarias se esfuerzan para ajustarse a
este problema antes de la pandemia uno
de cada tres centros en el mundo no
tenía la capacidad de tratar los
residuos de manera segura lo más seguro
es que este número haya crecido
entonces raúl que implica no poder
reciclar o tener que gastar todas estas
cantidades de toneladas de residuos por
culpa de la pandemia principalmente una
contaminación del medio ambiente que a
medio y a largo plazo también termina
implicando consecuencias para la salud
por ejemplo en contaminación del agua de
las comunidades que están alrededor de
centros médicos también contaminación
del aire y los problemas respiratorios
que eso puede conllevar porque hay
muchos centros que no tienen la
posibilidad de reciclar y lo que
terminan haciendo es quemar los residuos
que se generan en esta lucha contra la
pandemia también puede afectar si no se
hace bien a los trabajadores sanitarios
pues porque se pueden infectar al tocar
o al gestionar estos residuos una cosa
muy básica que podemos hacer todos para
empezar es por ejemplo dejar de usar los
guantes los guantes se ha demostrado que
en realidad no sirven para mucho y menos
para la población general es mejor
siempre lavarse las manos antes recogen
más por la por la textura de los guantes
marc y también por favor los tapabocas
puedes votar los en los desechos donde
tienen que votar es muy triste ver esta
para bocas por toda la calle playa ríos
bueno terminamos con una buena noticia
porque no todo es vale en esta sección
de salud la vacuna española contra el
kobe 19 avanza mar no hay luz al final
del túnel eso siempre lo estamos
diciendo estamos esperando todavía que
lleguen más información al respecto de
esta noticia pero sabemos ya que este
candidato vacunal de la empresa española
y para está entrando en la tercera fase
que es la última de estudios este ensayo
será con 3.000 personas adultas que
recibirán la vacuna como una dosis de
refuerzo durante 52 semanas estará
recogiendo información de estas personas
para asegurarse pues de que la vacuna
sea eficaz y de que la vacuna sea segura
lo más probable es que no tengamos que
esperar estas 52 semanas para saber los
resultados preliminares que esperamos
que sean buenos así es marc muchísimas
gracias entonces por esta sección de
salud me encanta compartir con usted
usted ya bien lo sabe así como todo el
resto del equipo es feliz de estar otra
vez aquí con usted raúl gracias vamos
ahora a saludar a nuestra según diputado
al día